mein name ist zu daran
ich bin ein nördliches breitmaulnashorn
ich sehe nicht besonders gut was da sind
meine bodyguards
sie sind rund um die uhr bei mir und
beschützen mich vor wilderern die jetzt
auf meinen horn abgesehen haben ganz
schön viel aufwand für ein altes nashorn
vielleicht nicht der letzte männliche
vertreter meiner art bin
hey sudan
[Musik]
ich besuche sodann in seinem zuhause
einen privat reservaten mitten in kenia
wir drehen diese dokumentation über
umweltzerstörung habitat verlust und
artensterben jetzt seit über zehn jahren
aber zum ersten mal mit ihr zu tun was
tatsächlich jetzt gerade ausstirbt
und wenn dieses tier stirbt war's das
mit dieser art da es tatsächlich
geschafft
etihad auszurotten
ein trauriges gefühl vor allem auch weil
es so ganz wilden verwandten nicht
besser geht
sie stehen alle in der schusslinie
[Musik]
allein in afrika werden jeden tag
mindestens drei männer getötet
wenn ich endlich etwas unternehmen
werden wir in wenigen jahren alle nass
oder verlorener
[Musik]
das kenianische schutzgebiet peter
sodann ist gerade aufgestanden und noch
ein wenig verschlafen
benannt ist der bulle nach seinem
heimatland im sudan kam er in den 1970
er jahren zur welt in freiheit
als kind wurde er von seiner familie
getrennt und in einen tschechischen zu
verfrachtet im rahmen eines
zuchtprogramms dann der umzug zurück in
die afrikanische savanne sudan ist seit
seiner kindheit an menschen gewöhnt nur
deshalb darf ich so nah an ihm dran an
meiner seite ist wildhüter sagte mir wie
jeden morgen bringt er den polen das
frühstück in seien knapp 3
quadratkilometer großes gehege
kraftfutter sprossen und
doch gut gefahren
aber nicht mehr gut zu fuß die
muskulatur seine hinterbeine ist schwach
auf dem linken auge sieht er kaum noch
was vermutlich alterserscheinungen sudan
ist 44 jahre ein sehr altes nashorn in
menschenjahren gerechnet wäre er etwa
100 er braucht ganz besondere pflege zur
fortpflanzung ist der senior allerdings
nicht mehr fähig auch fehlen geeignete
partnerinnen die beiden letzten
weiblichen vertreter des nördlichen
breitmaulnashorn es sind sudans tochter
nadine und seine enkelin vater die
traisen die letzten ihrer art von
wissenschaftlicher seite wird viel
unternommen um das nördliche
breitmaulnashorn noch vor dem aussterben
zu retten
versuche von künstlicher befruchtung
oder experimente mit stammzellen technik
um einen embryo zu züchten
[Musik]
masson aus dem reagenzglas
wieso handeln wir eigentlich immer erst
wenn es zu spät
warum lernen wir nicht aus unseren
fehler
jeden tag sterben über 100 arten aus die
meisten von ihnen unbemerkt still und
leise fernab der öffentlichkeit sudan
gibt den globalen artensterben immerhin
ein gesicht
[Musik]
neben den drei letzten nördlichen
breitmaulnashörnern gibt es in afrika
auch noch die südlichen
breitmaulnashörner mit rund 20.000
tieren bilden sie die häufigste nashorn
art gelten aber dennoch als bedroht
ebenso wie die spitzmaulnashörner die
mit etwas mehr als 5000 vertretern
ebenfalls im süden afrikas leben
[Musik]
auf dem asiatischen kontinent gibt es
drei weitere nashorn arten noch das
panzernashorn ist hauptsächlich in
indien zu hause sein bestand hat sich in
letzter zeit leicht erholt im gegensatz
zum kleinen sumatra nashorn mit
geschätzten 200 exemplaren und vom java
nashorn gibt es nur noch 60 tiere
zurück in europa in kenia es ist das
größte und wichtigste nashorn
schutzgebiet in ganz ostafrika
hier haben nicht nur die drei letzten
nördlichen breitmaulnashörner eine
heimat gefunden sondern auch 30 südliche
breitmaulnashörner
[Musik]
das 350 quadratkilometer große refugium
beherbergt außerdem auch viele andere
bedrohte tierarten
[Musik]
breitmaulnashörner sind die größte
nashorn art ausgewachsene männchen
können knapp vier meter lang und bis zu
dreieinhalb tonnen schwer werden
sie ernähren sich fast ausschließlich
von gräsern und genau deshalb ist er
breit und flach
ideal zum grasen spitzmaulnashörner
dagegen haben eine spitz zulaufende
oberlippe damit können sie auch mal
früchte oder blätter greifen
130 stützpfeiler sind ebenfalls hier in
europa zu hause und bald werden sie
einst mehr sein ist nicht erfreulich man
schwangeres spitzmüller sonst zu sehen
weil davon gibt es in ganz afrika noch
ungefähr 5000 stück
die mutter und ihr nachwuchs werden es
nicht leicht haben
die region wird von einer massiven
dürreperiode gebeutelt seit zwei jahren
hat es kaum geregnet im schutzgebiet von
europäischer wurden daher künstliche
wasserstellen errichtet ein angebot das
die tiere dankbar annehmen
trotz dieser hilfestellung ist es ein
täglicher kampf um ressourcen bei denen
sich meist der stärkere durchsetzt
[Musik]
nach vorne haben offensichtlich an
vielen fronten zu kämpfen selbst in
europa
doch zumindest ist die wilderei die
hauptbedrohung für nashörner in den
privaten schutzgebiet kein größeres
problem
ich bin verabredet mit richard wein dem
geschäftsführer des verbands 150 reines
hier und müssen damit rechnen dass wir
zwei bis drei nashörner im jahr an die
wilderei verlieren dann gibt es 14 oder
15 geburten und dann vielleicht noch
zwei tiere die eines natürlichen todes
sterben
insgesamt nimmt die population zu und
das ist schließlich unser ziel
was ist ihr erfolgsgeheimnis wir haben
aufwendige sicherheitsvorkehrungen
getroffen zum beispiel einen nashorn
schutztruppe die im ganzen reservat
unterwegs ist aufgabe der jungs ist
jedes einzelne nashorn alle zwei tage zu
testen
[Musik]
ein immenser aufwand und das nur wegen
ihres horns afrikanische nashörner haben
zwei davon das vordere horn wird im
schnitt etwa 90 cm lang und kann bis zu
vier kilogramm wiegen
auf dem schwarzmarkt ist ein kilogramm
momentan rund 50.000 euro wert eine
astronomische summe die viele
begehrlichkeiten weckt tausende von uns
müssen jedes jahr für ihr horn sterben
was wollt ihr menschen nur damit das ist
doch nur keratin nichts anderes als ihre
fingernägel oder haare
wir brauchen unser raum wir kämpfen
damit und territorien oder weibchen
legen eure waffen sind wir machtlos
in autos werden zum schutz der nashörner
auch hunde eingesetzt
manche von ihnen sind auf das
erschnüffeln von munition trainiert an
der auf menschliche gerüche der
belgische schäfer die ago wird darauf
spezialisiert wilderer zu stellen
ich bin heute ist ein schönes objekt
cheftrainer john gibt mir letzte
anweisungen
sobald du den hund sehen kannst fängst
du an zu rennen aber sehr vorsichtig wer
davon läuft ist für die jaguar ein
verbrecher mittlerweile gibt es länder
in afrika die wilderer ohne vorwarnung
erschießen
in europa dagegen baut man auf die
justiz bilder sollen verhaftet werden
die ago hilft bei der festnahme in dem
er sich im arm oder der hand verpasst
und die täter zu fall bringt der kernort
unglaubliche kraft der kirche ohne
schutzanzug will ich die akku nicht über
den weg laufen
es ist auch die agus verdienst dass hier
innerhalb der letzten 18 monate nur ein
einziges nashorn gewildert wurde
cheftrainer john berichtet was sonst
noch für diesen erfolg verantwortlich
ist wir helfen auch den umliegenden
gemeinden vor drei tagen zum beispiel
haben die diebe eine rinderherde aus
einem dorf gestohlen
unsere hunde haben ihre spur über 40
kilometer weit verfolgt die diebe
konnten wir zwar nicht fassen aber das
vieh haben wir zurück gebracht
was ist über der kripo hier bekämpft
verbrechen mit den hunden rund um das
schutzgebiet leben viele nomadische
stämme deren lebensgrundlage die
viehzucht ist die menschen profitieren
von peta
denn ihre rinderherden dürfen
kontrolliert innerhalb des
schutzgebietes weiden
so ist das finanz erich versorgt und
auch die existenz der hirten ist
gesichert
ein afrika weiteres problem menschliche
siedlungen reichen bis dicht an die
grenzen der schutzgebiete heran
[Musik]
die dort leben sind arm
es herrscht hohe arbeitslosigkeit und
perspektiven gibt es kaum vor allem
nicht für die jugend in diesen dörfern
werden oftmals wilderer rekrutiert
wenn man die wilderei effektiv bekämpfen
will muss man etwas gegen die armut in
afrika unternehmen und da sind auch wir
in europa gefragt
aber warum kommen so viele länder
afrikas trotz unserer entwicklungshilfe
nicht auf die beine
vielleicht wollen wir einfach kein
interesse daran haben
bei unser wohlstand auch auf der
ausbeutung dieser länder berühmt weil er
immer billigere rohstoffe wollen sind
wir also mitverantwortlich dafür dass
nation in der savanne staaten müssen
hannes jänicke reist in das aktuelle
zentrum der wilderei südafrika hier
leben mit abstand die meisten nashörner
des kontinents das lockt milderer an
jeden tag werden in südafrika momentan
mindestens drei nashörner getötet für
ein paar kilo horn nur wenige überleben
die brutalen attacken schwer verletzt
wenn die hilfe engagierter tierärzte
rechtzeitig eintrifft haben die opfer
eine chance die tiefen wunden müssen
versorgt werden damit sie sich nicht
entzünden
während seelische wunden kaum heilen
können wir zumindest das horn
nachwachsen
[Musik]
doch einen guten ausgang gibt es für die
wenigsten tiere
die bedrohung ist akut und spielbar
auch für uns sind unterwegs zu einem
nasa und waisenhaus von dem mir weder
eine adresse haben noch den genauen
namen dieses seit monaten mit den
betreibern dieser einrichtung in kontakt
und die wollten uns nichts weiter sagen
als den namen eines highways und einen
gewissen kilometerstand und hinter
diesem kilometerzähler gibt es angeblich
ein unscheinbares gatter und dort sind
wir mit den leuten verabredet
die angst vor überfällen ist offenbar
riesengroß so unmittelbar habe ich es
noch nirgendwo sonst erlebt
das könnte es sei normal
das ist nicht weiter der ist ja echt gut
versteckte ein abgeriegeltes tor nach
wenigen minuten tauchen zwei mitarbeiter
des weißen hauses auf sie sollen ihnen
folgen es ist wie ein krimi wir waren
noch gut fünf kilometer auf
schotterstraßen landeinwärts bis für das
waisenhaus erreicht von außen sieht es
allerdings eher aus wie ein
hochsicherheitsgefängnis
hier werden die kleinsten opfer der
wilderei wieder aufgepäppelt im kern vor
wild waisenhaus leben zurzeit mehr als
30 kleine nase und kinder und die haben
hunger
gemeinsam mit der chefin der einrichtung
petronell breit sich das mittag ist zu
milch angereichert mit proteinen und
traum zugang
die freier wildbahn sind nashörner in
der regel einzelkinder und drei jahre
lang von ihren müttern abhängig es ist
eine der engsten bindungen im tierreich
viele der babys die hierbei per tunnel
wieder zu kräften kommen haben
dramatisches erlebt sie mussten mit
ansehen wie ihre wichtigste bezugsperson
brutal getötet wurde
ganz allein im bus hätten die kleinen
dickhäuter traum eine überlebenschance
regional und ihr rettungsteam haben
schon über 100 babys vor dem sicheren
tod sowie die kleine siebe
sie wurde im winter 2015 mit einer
schussverletzung in petronas obhut
gebracht
wilderer haben nicht nur ihre mutter
getötet sondern es auch auf sie bus
kleines haus abgesehen dass jung hat den
angriff schwer verletzt überlebt und ist
auf dem weg der genesung
solange sie in der quarantäne station
sind bringen wie die nashörner über
nacht in stallungen auch aus
sicherheitsgründen
sobald wir sie dann in ein größeres
areal ausbildern können bekommen die
tiere von uns eine schutztruppe an die
seite gestellt
die überwachen sie tag und nacht wir
müssen müssen müssen wir haben so sehr
um ihr leben gekämpft und können sie
jetzt nicht einfach sich selbst
überlassen
petronell spricht aus bitterer erfahrung
wo fünf jahren sind schwer bewaffnete
männer gewaltsam des weißen haus
eingedrungen haben eines der größe und
tiere erschossen und sein horn gebildet
der schock sitzt immer noch tief
wieso haben wir kapieren langsam wie
riesig die bedrohung ist das sind
kriminelle mörder gewalttätige das hier
ist kein armut ding mehr weil der
wilderer sonst seine familie nicht
ernähren kann oder so was
das ist längst vorbei da steckt das
organisierte verbrechen dahinter so
nickel die kriminelle syndikate arbeiten
meist nachts und mit tödlicher präzision
sie sind hoch gerüstet ein grund warum
die zahl der erlegten nashörner in den
letzten zehn jahren in südafrika um mehr
als das 80 fache gestiegen ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich will wissen was man gegen diese
übermacht unternehmen kann die
südafrikanische organisation er setzt
auf moderne technik auf drohnen
ausgestattet mit nachtsicht und
wärmebildkameras die fluggeräte können
über zwei stunden lang in der luft
bleiben und haben dabei eine reichweite
von rund 25 kilometern
george einer der gründer der
organisation wird den heutigen einsatz
leiten
das ist der plan für heute
momentan liegen wir zwei arten von
einsätzen zum einen patroullieren wir im
verborgenen lautlos ohne licht in einer
höhe von 70 bis 100 metern
das ist eine ziemliche effektive methode
noch effektiver allerdings ist die
sichtbare überwacht die unsichtbare flug
mission soll will der banden aufspüren
bevor sie ihren tödlichen auftrag in der
savanne ausführen
die offenkundige präsenz dagegen wirkt
abschreckend
weil es in kombination bringt den
größten erfolg die überwachung aus der
luft durch die eher shepherd setzt die
hohen mafia unter enormen druck
dieses mal wurden die hüter der lüfte
von einem kleinen schutz reservat in der
nähe von johannesburg beauftragt entlang
seiner grenzen zu patroullieren
sobald die drohne in der luft ist
beginnt die arbeit in der mobilen
einsatzzentrale einem camper die
nachtsichtkamera überträgt ihre bilder
live auf die monitore
dabei kommt eine spezielle software zum
einsatz
die vorab festgelegte formen zb personen
nashörner oder elefanten automatisch
erkennt die technik macht dabei weniger
fehler als der mensch sobald das
programm etwas auffälliges entdeckt
übernehmen george um sein team so wie
jetzt eine bewegung am boden und
vermutlich ein fahrzeug
die stelle wird auf geringerer höhe
umkreist siehst du das eindeutig
menschen am boden der typen ging echt
gas jetzt haben die gescheckte sie aus
der luft gefilmt werden
nein unmöglich wir sehen uns nicht
wie haben sie es aber richtig eigentlich
wir informieren jetzt die örtlichen
ranger die sollen sich das mal genauer
ansehen ist der alarm berechtigt
übernehmen die bodentruppen
damit endet die heutige mission der er
schätze die luftüberwachung wirkt dort
wo drohnen patroullieren sinkt die
wilderei merklich
motto der geschäftsführer von airport
erzählt mir dass die bodentruppen dank
der drohen viel seltenen schießereien
oder einen hinterhalt geraten
der job der ranger bleibt dennoch
gefährlich man muss sie für ihr
engagement bewundern
doch auch in ihren reihen gibt es
schwachstellen
viele ranger sind unterbezahlt man
erwartet von ihnen das ihren job machen
weil sie ihn mögen und ihr herz für
umwelt und tiere schlägt ich glaube die
realität ist völlig anders
stell dir mal vor du verdienst schlecht
und bis täglich mit einem tier
konfrontiert das einhorn mehr wert ist
als gold oder diamanten manche wechseln
die seiten und versuchen auch mit dem
horn geld zu machen
die ranger stehen aber vermutlich auf
der niedrigsten stufe der korruption wie
weit ich sie denn in südafrika
verbreitet das gilt bis in die
regierungsebene
es ist kein geheimnis dass unser
sicherheitsminister eine verbindung zu
einer bekannten nashorn händler hat die
internationale presse berichtete über
den fall
auch bei uns
und der mann ist immer noch mal ja
so offen die otto spricht kaum einer vor
laufender kamera über das massive
korruptionsproblem aber ist es nicht so
dass ab einer gewissen summe jeder von
uns käuflich ist
wenn viel geld im spiel ist dann
bröckelt irgendwann auch die moral die
routen für schmuggler sind offen
landesgrenzen zollbehörden
bestechungsgelder machen den weg frei
wie effektiv das geschäft ist das ist
einfache mathematik rund 1000 nashörner
wurden allein in südafrika 2016
gewildert das entspricht einer menge von
etwa 6000 kilogramm horn offiziell
sichergestellt wurde davon allerdings
nur ein bruchteil
es müssen also enorme mengen an das horn
im umlauf sein
hannes jänicke folgt der blutigen spur
in das land das als grösster abnehmer
für nashorn gilt vietnam die hauptstadt
des landes hanoi wirkt extrem moderne
verlässt man jedoch die großen straßen
wird schnell klar dass die stadt auch
ein zweites ein traditionelles
gesichtert
in diesem alten hanoi wimmelt es von
apotheken die sich auf traditionelle
chinesische medizin spezialisiert haben
in den rezepturen spielt das rhinozeros
horn eine große rolle
bereits seit der antike angeblich soll
es gegen fieber entzündungen oder
arthritis helfen doch welchen
stellenwert hat so eine behauptung in
einem modernen gärtner sie als apotheker
glauben sie an einen medizinischen
effekt von das in unserem traditionellen
büchern heißt es das nashorn
entzündungshemmend ist heute ist es
verboten ich verkaufe nur noch
wasserbüffel horn der apotheker schreibt
mir eine adresse auf von einer bekannten
die angeblich nach vorn als medizin für
sich nutzt
import handel und besitz von nashorn
sind nach dem washingtoner
artenschutzabkommen seit 1977 streng
verboten
auch in vietnam doch seit knapp zehn
jahren ist doch die nachfrage regelrecht
explodiert als ein ehemaliges
regierungsmitglied propagiert hat dass
ihm das horn vom krebs geheilt hat ein
hinterhof in hanoi hier wohnten system
bei ihr wurde vor fünf jahren magenkrebs
diagnostiziert sind außerdem die ihren
echten namen will sie mir nicht verraten
denn sie weiß dass sie etwas illegales
tut wenn sie nass man verwendet es ist
tea gilt heute als geheilt
sie war längst auch lange in
schulmedizinische behandlung das hat
ihnen rückblicken mehr geholfen im
system war es die westliche behandlung
mit der chemotherapie oder die
traditionelle asiatische medizin
ich habe beides ausprobiert und ich
denke dass die kombination gut war und
es mir deshalb besser geht
was von beidem besser gewirkt hat kann
ich wirklich nicht sagen
majesty hat noch einen rest von zu hause
das erste mal dass ich so etwas sehe das
horn wurde gehobelt es sieht eigentlich
aus wie sehr gespannt
jetzt kommt warmes wasser drauf und
schon ist die vermeintliche medizin
fertig es riecht genau wie verbranntes
haar
letztendlich ist es auch nichts anderes
keratin eine medizinische wirkung konnte
nie nachgewiesen werden es ist die hat
der horn übrigens von der tochter
bekommen
wissen sie zufällig wo ihre tochter
gekauft hat nein keine ahnung
meine tochter hat es auch geschenkt
bekommen soweit ich weiß
niemand weiß etwas niemand verkauft es
offiziell
und doch ist es offensichtlich zu haben
ich will wissen wo die quelle des
illegalen nashorn handelns ist und
telefoniere mit einem vietnamesischen
investigative journalisten nahm zu seit
jahren recherchierte undercover
henderson
am nächsten tag bin ich mit hoher
verabredet er will mir beweisen wie
einfach einen guten namen nashorn kaufen
kann man muss nur wissen wo wir
verlassen die hauptstadt
wenn einer erwischt wird beim kauf von
us um was passiert da ist es gefährlich
braun zu kaufen oder zu verkaufen ist
per gesetz verboten
aber unsere regierung bestrafte den
großen quasi den geschäftlichen handel
mit horn wenn eine privatperson nashorn
konsumiert wurde ein kleines stück horn
zu hause hat wird er strafrechtlich so
gut wie nie verfolgt als konsument hat
nicht von staatlicher seite schon mal
nichts zu befürchten
doch in der händler szene ist es laut
ungefährlich die händler sitzen in einem
dorf namens nikkei alle fäden sollen dir
zusammenlaufen nikkei gilt als
hauptumschlagplatz für nass
man kann sich hier nicht mehr blicken
lassen während seiner recherchen wurde
er bereits mehrfach zusammen geschlagen
und bedroht
beim kleinsten verdacht macht die
händler die huang hat deshalb zwei
bergleute mitgebracht
sie werden von uns mit versteckten
kameras ausgestattet
glück euch beiden konnten wieder die
beiden geben vor nashorn für ihre kranke
mutter kaufen zu wollen
gleich im ersten laden werden sie fündig
der händler holt eine ordentliche menge
nashorn späne aus einem hinterzimmer
es gibt einen mindestabnahme preis der
liegt bei 300 us dollar dafür bekommen
unsere beiden deck leute 70 gramm
nashorn
sie müssen kaufen sonst machen sie sich
verdächtig und bringen sich in gefahr
keine stunde später ist das horn in
meinem hotelzimmer angekommen
es ist erschreckend wie einfach das ging
das zeug hat erwiesenermaßen keinerlei
medizinische nuss aber bei krankheiten
werden wir menschen einfach irrational
nur warum ist naser mehr wert als gold
oder diamanten
das kann doch nicht nur am medizinischen
arbeit glauben liegen
[Musik]
um das herauszufinden trifft sich hannes
jänicke noch einmal mit dem journalisten
horn auf einem picknick areal außerhalb
hanoi hat der ein treffen mit einem
reichen geschäftsmann arrangiert der
regelmäßig nashorn konsumiert allerdings
nicht aus medizinischen gründen
auch er will unerkannt bleiben laut
statistik ist er der typische konsument
männlich mittleren alters erfolgreich
und brav
jahrhundert mir erzählt dass im ersten
versuch ihren warum und wieso tun sie
das meine freunde und ich nehmen dass
wenn wir zu viel getrunken haben auf
einer party das hilft uns gegen den
kater haben sie jemals aspirin
ausprobiert ein westliches anti kater
mit
wir haben in unserer medizin auch noch
andere kräuter die gegen kater helfen
aber nach vorn ist definitiv am besten
der geschäftsmann besitzt ein stück
unbehandeltes horn
es wird in einem speziellen schleif
behälter gefüllt mit tee und wein
zermahlen
es ist pervers ein anti kater mittel für
das ein nasa und sterben musste
andererseits sind wir auch nur einen
deut besser die europäer machen immerhin
auf weiße weste essen aber selbst
gänsestopfleber
schmeißen lebende hummer ins heiße
wasser oder trank pelz ausgezogen
für unseren eigenen - ist es
offensichtlich okay wenn tiere qualvoll
leiden oder sterben müssen
[Musik]
aus höflichkeit probiere ich den hohen
sucht er schmeckt genauso wie er riecht
nach verbranntem h der geschäftsmann
erklärte schließlich warum die nachfrage
und deshalb auch die preise verloren in
den letzten jahren so explodiert sind
davon ist heute ein statussymbol bei uns
in vietnam
lange zeit konnten es sich nur könige
oder hohe offizielle leisten
die leute glauben es macht was her weil
man es zu hause hat
unser halten statussymbolen
dafür tötet ihr uns
findet doch immer einen grund wollte
unser horn als mediziner luxus artikel
lud als trophäe aber ist es uns egal ob
wir durch die kugel eines wilderers oder
die eines großen hit jägers sterben
warum lasst ihr uns nicht einfach in der
einfluss der jagd industrien afrika ist
groß es ist ein milliardengeschäft
bis zu 300.000 euro blättern so genannte
sportler auf den tisch um beispielsweise
ein spitzmaulnashorn abzuknallen ganz
legal posieren mit einem vom aussterben
bedrohten tiere
[Musik]
wer für sein jagd vergnügen bezahlt er
wird damit auch das recht dass vorn
auszuführen
trotz weltweitem handelsverbot als
trophäe deklariert kann es dann auch in
viele länder der welt ganz legal
eingeführt werden
auch nach deutschland wieso gibt es
nicht längst ein generelles importverbot
für trophäen bedrohte arten
wirtschaftliche interessen sind
anscheinend immer noch wichtiger als das
tierwohl
hannes jänicke ist zurück in südafrika
hier ist er jetzt verabredet mit john
hume auch der will mit nashörnern
geschäfte machen
er züchtet sie südafrika ist das einzige
land in dem sich renault kasse in
privatbesitz befinden dürfen
und wenn schon jung sind das eine ganze
menge 1508 ihre nennt er sein eigen
eine größenordnung die unerreicht ist
weltweit nahmen sie sind der
erfolgreichsten larssons düstere welt
was ist ihr geheimnis
ein grund ist sicher dass ich ein
offenes und flaches stück land
ausgewählt habe wilderer können sich
hier kaum verstecken
willst du erfolg dann musst du
erfolgreich züchten und erfolgreich
schützen
das hört sich vernünftig an aber
letztendlich ist jugend geschäftsmann
seine nashörner bewohnen eine
savannenlandschaft von insgesamt 80
quadratkilometern
zusammen mit anderen wildtieren auf
dieser riesigen fläche werden die tiere
strikt gemanagt
es gibt camps in denen die weibchen ihre
jungen aufziehen und separate gehege für
die zuchtbullen wenn ein jungtier zu
schwach ist oder die mutter keine milch
gibt wird es in das waisenhaus der fan
gebracht
die kleinen bewohner bleiben in
menschlicher pflege bis sie etwa vier
jahre alt und damit geschlechtsreif sind
danach werden sie umgesiedelt in die
größeren camps und nehmen dann am
eigentlichen zuchtprogramm teil
alle 28 monate bringen die weiblichen
tiere hier ein kind zur welt
ist die geburtenrate hier ähnlich wie in
freier wildbahn
sie ist besser im letzten finanzjahr
hatten wir rund 200 geburten
doch nashörner sind teuer in der haltung
knapp 300.000 euro monatlich kosten
arbeiter futter und medizinische
versorgung der großteil des budgets
fließt jedoch in die sicherheit
privatarmee starkstrom zäune und
videoüberwachung jung hofft dass sich
seine investitionen bald rechnen
ich kann nicht ewig so weitermachen
mein geld reicht noch für zwei oder drei
jahre dann muss ich das hier dichtmachen
wenn du in zwölf jahren wieder kommst
werden all die nashörner hier tot sein
außer ich bekomme eine enorme
geldspritze in der nächsten zeit und wie
stelle ich das an das logischste ist
dass die nashörner das ganze finanzieren
zu lassen das ist die einzig sinnvolle
lösung
und finanzieren sollen die nashörner die
fahren natürlich mit ihrem wertvollen
horn
das wird hier nämlich schon mal geerntet
ich bin es bei einer so genannten
enthüllungsaktion dabei wir jagen einem
fast siebenjährigen zuchtbullen
kriterien
er muss betäubt werden
die tierärztin hat erfahren volltreffer
eine solche enthornung findet ihr
mindestens zweimal pro woche statt eine
spezialeinheit mit maschinengewehren
sichert jetzt das gelände großräumig ab
es muss schnell gehen die betäubung wird
noch knapp 20 minuten anhalten die
narkose birgt aber immer auch ein
gesundheitliches risiko für die tiere
jetzt wird es ernst
eine motorsäge kommt zum einsatz
[Musik]
jedes tier wird etwa alle zwei jahre
entfernt jung konnte so einen vorrat von
sechs tonnen nashorn anhäufen
grob geschätzt ist der einen
dreistelligen millionenbetrag wert
allerdings nur in der theorie denn
bisher ist das horn unverkäuflich der
besitz ist in südafrika unter gewissen
auflagen zwar legal der handel aber
verboten so bleibt schon jung nichts
anderes übrig als sein geerntetes horn
sicher in banken und tresoren zu
deponieren und auf bessere zeiten zu
hoffen
angeblich spüren die tiere nichts wenn
man die horn absägt
für mich sieht das allerdings anders aus
die beiden hörner wiegen insgesamt knapp
drei kilogramm jedes abgetrennte horn
muss mit einem mikrochip markiert und
registriert werden
so schreibt es die südafrikanische
regierung vor für den bullen ist die
prozedur jetzt vorbei bis in zwei jahren
dann wird sein horn ungefähr 20 cm nach
gewachsen sein und erneut geerntet das
horn ist für john hume ein
nachwachsender rohstoff ist überrascht
mich nicht dass jung im legalen handel
mit nashorn die einzige möglichkeit
sieht nashorn in freier natur zu
schützen
eine überzeugung für die er intensive
lobbyarbeit auf staatlicher ebene
beträgt
[Musik]
legales und illegales hahn auf dem markt
für mich schnitten man beim handelt
völlig die kontrolle verliert unser
hohes nummeriert und dna getestet das
muss man halt mit allen hörnern so
machen
nichts einfacher als das und alle hörner
die nicht kategorisiert sind sind
daneben illegal kaserne müssen nicht
sterben für ehrhorn es braucht bloß
einen legalen markt für vietnamesische
konsumenten aber wir machen gerade das
genaue gegenteil wir überlassen den
markt komplett den wilderern und die
tüten unsere nashörner
[Musik]
wenige wochen nach unseren dreharbeiten
hat john hume einen fragwürdigen
teilerfolg errungen
südafrika hat den handel mit nashorn
inländisch wieder zugelassen
doch wo wird eine solche entscheidung
hinführen john hume hat im august 2017
sein geerntetes horn auf einer auktion
zum verkauf angeboten
durch die südafrikaner haben überhaupt
kein interesse an der wahl
die werbung im netz in japanischer und
chinesischer sprache zählt auf den
eigentlichen markt
die händler dürfen das ersteigerte horn
aber nur mit extrem hohen bürokratischen
aufwand exportieren
zu hause ist ein import und handel
wieder verboten das macht alles
irgendwie keinen sinn ist die option
also nur ein erster schritt in richtung
vollständige legalisierung des handelns
mit dem horn durch den verkauf nicht ein
legaler wert und nutzen zugesprochen ist
es nicht insgesamt ein fatales signal
[Musik]
dieser meinung ist im übrigen auch der
frankfurter zoodirektor professor
manfred niekisch
niekisch ist ein vehementer gegner des
handels mit nashorn vor allem weil es
bereits erfahrungswerte aus dem lager
verkauf von elfenbein gibt eine
erfahrung aus der wir seiner meinung
nach lernen sollten
die vorstellung tiere zu züchten die
ansonsten hoch bedroht sind nur um sie
kommerziell zu nutzen und dann damit
auch noch einen illegalen markt zu
ermöglichen dass es einfach ein
riesenproblem und wenn das geerntete
nasen hand auf dem markt käme dann würde
mit sicherheit die wilderei noch stärker
zunehmen das wissen wir aus dem
elfenbeinhandel wenn es nur ein signal
gibt es gibt legalen markt dann geht die
wilde reise fort ich will da reißt auch
bei uns in europa längst angekommen
im märz 2007 wurde in einem zoo bei
paris ein nashorn getötet um sein horn
abgesägt außerdem wurden hohen exponate
aus naturgeschichtlichen museen
gestohlen
die lage ist ernst selbst deutsche zoos
mussten ihre sicherheitsvorkehrungen
verstärken
[Musik]
ferner werden für mich immer mehr zum
symbol dafür wie verquer unser umgang
mit tieren natur eigentlich ist
wir lieben unsere haustiere und
verdrängen die massen tieren
wir setzen uns für einen besseren schutz
bedrohter tiere in afrika einlassen aber
genau dieselben tiere bei uns zuhause
kunststückchen vorträgen sowie die nasa
und bullen sarow im zirkus co mit seinen
41 jahren ist sowohl das dienstälteste
und mittlerweile einzige zirkus nashorn
in deutschland seit seiner kindheit
steht in der man menschen
wer bitte wie so etwas noch sie
immer weniger im gegensatz zu
deutschland ist es in 20 anderen eu
ländern komplett oder teilweise verboten
wildtiere wie elefanten giraffen oder
eben nashörner in zirkussen auftreten zu
lassen oder zu halten
in den auftritt freien monaten lebt sie
in seinem sogenannten winterquartier dem
krone zogen ein kleines beton gehege
welche daseinsberechtigung haben den
wildtieren im zirkus
es wird nichts gelehrt gelernt oder
vermittelt außerdem eindruck dass sogar
wilde tiere das machen was wir menschen
wollen ein generelles verbot von
wildtieren im zirkus ist längst
überfällig
[Musik]
ein kluger mensch hat einmal gesagt dass
die größe und der moralische fortschritt
eine nation daran gemessen werden können
wie sie ihre tiere behandelt das war
mahatma gandhi ich glaube wir haben noch
einiges aufzuholen
[Musik]
eigentlich ist es doch gar nicht so
schwer
die menschen müssten einfach nur
begreifen dass er nicht über der natur
steht sondern ein teil von ihr seid aber
ich bin alt das werde ich wohl nicht
mehr leben
für dich und deine art sudan ist es
leider zu spät aber vielleicht schafft
es ja irgendwie seine wilde
verwandtschaft noch zu wenden
[Musik]